what is happening there reject nation
greg here today holding down the fort
still while john is out of commission
recovering from surgery
for getting a knuckle sandwich to his
teeth that's why he was missing one get
it knuckles is a family-friendly joke
for this family-friendly movie guys we
got ourselves a sonic the hedgehog 2
final trailer i'm excited to watch this
man i thought the first trailer was
awesome it looks way more
exciting and cinematic already you got
to be trapped in here with me for just a
tiny bit longer i promise and yeah if
you guys can hit the like button that'd
be very much appreciated anyway let's
see this let's see this thing all right
fine you can go
[Music]
these rings signify the commitment
[Music]
so help me thomas sorry sorry
life or death situation i need you to
use the ring to save me like right now
my god oh boy
oh wedding wrecked ah hawaii i just hope
we are not too late oh lord there are
two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
robotnik is back
i discovered the source of ultimate
power master aberrate we need to get it
back for the world is doomed
you rock some kind of
space porcupine
i am an echidna warrior
ooh badass man
hedgehog
it's time to say goodbye to humanity
oh [ __ ] welcome
to the new norm oh what
a moment
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh
someone call an uber
it's cold in here
let's turn up the heat
oh awesome
oh so it's not a skateboarding
snowboarder
she's running pieces that's cool
i'll break the winter soldier
fear not citizens you are terrible at
this your negative attitude is not
helping
we stick together
no matter what that looks pretty
imposing whoa
untrained
unworthy
you forgot one
unstoppable
[Music]
they're watching a dbz fight
man that death egg looks insane
i love that imposing shot where he's
just like this big shadow with the red
eyes at the top so good this looks so
much better than the first one i overall
enjoyed the first one but this looks
like a major step up you know what that
last part kind of reminded me of tell me
if this flashed to your mind at all do
you remember the episode of pokemon when
pikachu fought riochu and raichu just
kept like beating his ass and then
pikachu had realized that he could out
speed him while raichu was more powerful
that's kind of what i thought of there
dbz versus the pikachu versus raichu
fight where it seems like knuckles
obviously more powerful however sonic
might be able to out strategize him and
outspeed him because he's clearly like
dodging him a bunch just a little food
for thought anyway yeah this trailer
just gave me some more of what i loved
about the first one it's exciting it's
thrilling the word that weirdly keeps
coming to mind for me is it just looks
so much more cinematic the peril
actually feels really felt one of those
shots in there was so ominous the death
egg where it's like this big looming
shadow over sonic it's really
threatening and imposing red eyes and
that's all that's really colorful about
that silhouette shot of the death egg at
the very bottom you see like sonic he's
like limping his way he's really worn
out and tired and just beaten down
limping towards the emerald he's all
like dirtied up just seems like it's
gonna be a real struggle for sonic
something that the first trailer seemed
to lean in on was how sonic was you know
trying to be more of a hero right now
and i'm kind of curious what his journey
here might be because like in the first
one a lot of it dealt with like run away
from your problems now face your
problems and then here i'm sort of
curious to see like what sonic's arc
ultimately might be would emotional
challenges behold him at this particular
moment in time there's a popular theory
going around and i'm wondering if it's
going to be infused in here at all i'm
like i haven't read a single damn leak
about this movie so i don't know if
there's any leaks out there about it but
a popular theory because like when
you're in angel city if i'm not mistaken
in angel city where knuckles and sonic
are versing each other all those statues
are resembling longhawk who we didn't
see die at the beginning of the first
sonic movie but she still sacrificed
herself so it wasn't an on-screen death
she could very much be alive and the
common theory that i'm hearing is like
maybe the echidna went after longhawk
because she's somehow connected to the
master emerald in some way i don't
really know like the ins and outs or
details of why that would line up but
then you see all this owl imagery and i
feel like you got to bring that back you
got to bring that back home like why was
longhawk really protecting sonic i
really want to see that be more fleshed
out and perhaps you know especially with
establishing in the trailer that
knuckles as an echidna warrior that he
might learn something like you're the
people who killed my mom or the one who
protected me like he might have some
type of revenge vengeance driven motive
a vengeance you might
have some type of like revenge motive
because of how serious he seems to be
taking it how personal this seems to
really be for him and then you got these
moments here with dr robotnik that also
threw me for a loop a little bit i know
there's been some tv spots that are out
there i haven't seen them so i don't
know how much of this is completely
brand new but for me it's been pretty
new when you're looking at dr robotnik
when he's coming out of this shop it
looks like he's from my understanding
feel free to correct me because i'm by
no means a self-proclaimed sonic expert
i thought like with the master emerald
that that power be used solely for his
machinery something along the lines were
just like the death egg right and then
here it looks like somehow his body was
managed to like draw some power from it
or fuse with it or interface with it in
some way like i don't really know how
he's doing any of that but that looks
cool that looks sinister it would seem
like the plot of this would probably go
something like this when it comes to
what the finale might be and if it is
this case i'm so glad they're not
showing it in the trailers because
they're really letting it seem like hey
you got knuckles and dr robotnik going
after sonic that seems to be like
they're keeping at the focus i imagine
at some point here knuckles and sonic
kind of like bvs or any of these like
versus movies and knuckles and sonic
would eventually come to some kind of
understanding and then knuckles would
see that he sided with the wrong person
he sided with dr robotic the one he
shouldn't be with and then they along
with tails would be fighting dr robotnik
at the end of this movie while he's in
the death act like sonic looks like he
cannot take on the death egg by himself
so he would probably need some help and
i imagine he would get it from knuckles
and tails have them in the movie and
then the sequel you could get that you
know and then set up shadow sonic i'm
sure i think a lot of people really want
that and with like having uh the gun
army involved in here feel like they're
establishing some little seeds for
getting shadow sonic to get involved in
this franchise now i mean like i'm
loving the action scenes i'm loving
everything that we're seeing the
expansions of it i feel like calling
this final trailer is a relief because i
think this is plenty this is enough and
it still looks like funny you know it
doesn't look hilarious but it still
looks funny and charming like very
amusing still feels like a family
friendly movie while being something
that even more adults can enjoy one
thing though that i'm hoping is just so
strong in reserve for the movie because
it's going to be such a highlight i'm
hoping it's a highlight sometimes and
this is like a minor critique more of a
nitpick more than anything else they
don't really showcase tales so much or
at least i don't feel like they're
really promoting tails all that much i
want to get like a better sense of the
chemistry between sonic and tails
because sometimes when i'm watching the
trailer it really feels like
someone in a voiceover booth talking
like i'm not feeling the chemistry
between them when that's such a vital
part i really hope that that really
clicks because while i'm sure it's gonna
be good and fine i want it to be
something that you walk away from this
movie going hey that's sonic and tails
man they were they were a great duo they
were really fun together but anyway yeah
this is a great trailer it's just as
strong as the first one even better
actually thanks for being here guys
appreciate you sticking around me and uh
hey subscribe leave a like button last
but not least stupid
i'm mariam i just want to shut you up
and give you a real sincere one right
now i posted some video the other day
and you sent me a message on twitter
that i i thought was like very
like it put me at ease it made me feel
really calm at the time i really needed
to read that so i just want to say uh
thank you for um being honest with me
and expressing that because that
truly did um you know made me feel
made me feel relaxed and for to go from
anxious to feeling relaxed is just a
real gift so i want to thank you for
just all the support that you've been
giving us and for opening up your heart
to me in so many ways like your your
real gem your real joy you're my master
emerald there tighter than sonic love
you dear thank you
[Music]